you guys ever go to a brunch with your
friends
this is something I do I'll go to brunch
and I try to tell myself I'm like I'm
gonna eat healthy at this Branch
everyone is gonna eat like pigs but I'm
gonna eat healthy then I get there and I
tell the waiter oh I'll just have some
scrambled eggs and some avocado
um
and everyone orders and the waiter's
like all right I'll be right back I'll
be back soon with your your orders
and I always go wait
um
can we get some pancakes for the table
I swear and then I just eat the pancakes
just order pancakes
stop this
chocolate chip pancakes man that's
my favorite
I also like French toast oh man
the powdered sugar huh
[Music]
so good